bienvenidos a reporteros en esta
oportunidad de reporteros en el
documental gracias por estar con
nosotros comenzamos china está presente
en todos los países africanos y se sitúa
como uno de los primeros socios
comerciales del continente estableciendo
una especie de relación que muchos
llaman sin áfrica pero su influencia
despierta recelos en zambia una de las
naciones más pobres del mundo el gigante
asiático ha focalizado su inversión los
vínculos comerciales entre beijing y
lusaka la capital son estrechos y se
remontan a varias décadas hoy china
posee un tercio de la deuda nacional de
zambia actúa en los sectores industrial
minero y agrícola nutriéndose de materia
prima del continente esto ha llevado a
que algunos anv ya nos denuncien un
nuevo modelo de colonialismo tres de
nuestros reporteros lograron acceder a
una de las empresas chinas y en el
continente esta es la historia
[Música]
apagado todo el mundo esta semana esta
semana más o menos el grupo m
hay que cobrarles nos deben 170 mil
dólares
creo que la hembra está preñada
a ese su mujer
que paisajista es muy buena
demandamos y bill evans que para mí
balance
es una ganga
hay mucho verde en nuestra fábrica estos
animales están ahí para simbolizar la
armonía entre el hombre y la naturaleza
cuando nuestros trabajadores vienen a
trabajar viven toda esta naturaleza los
pone de buen humor
[Música]
y estarán bien cuando hay una cámara son
muy productivos
[Música]
apostaremos
la seguridad es lo primero seguridad
seguridad
la seguridad es lo primero
en china la competencia es dura
en la industria las utilidades siguen
cayendo
en 2007 un amigo mío me propuso ir con
él a zambia donde todo estaba por hacer
no sabía nada del sistema político y
económico del país
durante dos años trabajé en una fábrica
del año
no lo más tu mascarilla no cubre tu
nariz
en el momento no hablaba mucho inglés
he aprendido el idioma dos años más
tarde empecé mi propio negocio
por demás mi propia
la máquina está demasiado sucia habrá
que limpiar la hago costales
industriales para vender a las grandes
empresas de semillas de alimentación y
de cemento
en el sector privado de los productos
manufacturados somos el número uno
empecé mi negocio desde cero y hoy soy
una leyenda en la comunidad china y
empresa vale 250 millones de dólares
y todo ese terreno se compró para el
futuro desarrollo de la empresa
en 2017 monte en negocios de marcopolo
hacemos baldosas
el señor wang nuestro director general
es una persona excelente trabaje para y
gracias a él que estoy aquí
frank the line son muy amables les gusta
aprender pero olvidan muy rápido
el mineral proviene de nuestras propias
minas
es una planta de gas con el carbón el
gas se calienta para cocinar las
baldosas
y desde aquí controlamos la planta de
gas y se puede ver la estación de
policía que se construyó para la
comunidad
acá no había ninguna comisaría de
policía el jefe de la aldea nos pidió
que les ayudáramos y nuestro director el
señor wang dijo no hay problema les
construiremos uno
llevan un poco más adelante financiamos
una plantación para el hospital para eso
ya nosotros también construimos la
escuela aquí ganamos dinero pero también
intentamos mejorar las condiciones de
vida de nuestros amigos cambiamos
[Música]
la cuestión de la influencia china en
zambia es muy delicada hold on
y están vinculados a personas muy
poderosas a las que nadie quiere alienar
y hay corrupción tanto en los países en
desarrollo como en los países ricos
en eeuu esto se llama lobbies por
mobbing
estamos hablando de corrupción por
atenderlo
la realidad es que hoy en día en zambia
es mejor ser chino que cambiando
pincha en islandia dante en esa vida
[Música]
en la embajada no hablan no nos quieren
hablar
veo al embajador regularmente comemos y
cenamos juntos pero no hable en público
ya saben que no le agrada a nadie el
público
así que para esta sesión
mamá mamá
mama
[Aplausos]
ya han terminado de comer
ya que ya han terminado de una hora
aproximadamente
mis padres eran agricultores en chino
así que los traje aquí
allí su granja era más pequeña que la
mía
en unos 350 cerdos
pero para 2022 espero crear 3.000 sí
quieres matar esa no es demasiado
pequeño
en guayana
tengo casi 40 años como vivo en zambia
no podré cuidar de mis padres que ya son
mayores me hace sentir mejor tenerlos
cerca
no los alimente es demasiado ya han
comido bastante deja de alimentarlos
y nunca habían salido de china mi madre
me pregunta a menudo porque su piel es
tan oscura y la nuestra es amarilla y me
río
y le digo que tomaron mucho sol
mira te estás todo sucio
tiene 4 años
y quién es él
el hijo de nuestro mayordomo son amigos
es mayor que él
y estar en la escuela pero por culpa del
19 se queda en la granja
tenía seis meses cuando llegó a san
benito también comienza a hablar el
idioma local y allá
yo recibimos muchas visitas por aquí
ella es mi hija
su niñera es también muy escalador
en la fila
y mi vecino se llama jumping
desde la provincia de xinjiang
justo hay dos toneladas en casa
esta fruta está podrida se la comieron
las gallinas
cómo van las ventas hoy no está mal ya
he hecho dos entregas
[Música]
tiene la lealtad
en china la agricultura es difícil
cada vez hay menos tierra para cultivar
con el gobierno nos empuja a salir de
china
en china hay demasiadas personas hay
suficiente tierra
la competencia es dura si alguien debe
plantar fruta del dragón y ganar dinero
al día siguiente hace lo mismo
aquí soy el único chino aquí
y todos los empleados son zambianos
todos ganamos
nosotros los necesitamos y ellos nos
necesitan
también hay agua
y este país es muy cristiana algunos
piensan que fuimos enviados por dios
tienda
te aseguro que dan gracias a los demás
como enviados por dios nosotros
aquí
[Música]
son empresas chinas
todo está escrito en chino
estamos controlados por los chinos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la vida dura en este momento
los negocios se están cerrando a causa
del coronavirus a edad
[Música]
el gobierno no hace nada nos miente las
elecciones serán tensas la gente quiere
un cambio
nosotros sufrimos y ellos nos roban
as
este gobierno no tolera la corrupción el
frente patriótico es el partido de los
pobres de los campesinos del pueblo
zambiano de los agricultores de los
trabajadores de los estudiantes es el
partido de los patriotas no el de los
cortesanos ni el de los que quieren
robar a los votantes cuantos confiamos
en que su excelencia el presidente el
día agua lunghi
gane las elecciones presidenciales más
victorias
antonio monserrat portavoz del frente
patriótico se le conoce como el joven
obama
sánchez
china no le quita nada a cambiar al
contrario nos ha ayudado más que
occidente quien ha invertido miles de
millones en nuestras minas nuestras
infraestructuras nuestros sistemas de
comunicación nuestros transportes china
ha invertido miles de millones de
dólares en nuestra energía se ofrecen
mejores condiciones y nos ayuda a través
de la transferencia de tecnología china
seguirá siendo nuestro socio
aquí está el álbum con el presidente
lungo
nistal humedad
efe
he conocido a los presidentes kaunda
onda banda
sata y lugo
concordia lo que queremos para la
empresa es estabilidad de estudio en
cuanto a un nuevo gobierno significa un
cambio de política a diferencia de lo
que había lo que esperamos que el mundo
sea reelegido por cinco años
[Música]
todos los países necesitan inversores el
problema es la falta de transparencia en
los contratos con china se invirtió
mucho dinero en carreteras y hospitales
pero muchos proyectos estaban
sobrevalorados
hay mucha corrupción contratos hechos
para favorecer a los amigos
una carretera que cuesta 10 dólares
acaba costando 50
el gobierno no ha revelado el 100 por
ciento del alcance de nuestra relación
con china incluyendo cuánto le debemos a
la deuda externa supera los 10 mil
millones de dólares pero la deuda real
es aún mayor donde small and h
las empresas chinas están presentes en
muchos sectores están en todas partes
tenemos que proteger ciertas zonas y
dejarlas en manos de los cambia no solo
preguntan qué problemas tenemos con los
chinos
y esos chinos venden pollos en el
mercado aunque sean demasiado jóvenes y
los venden por menos
así que los ancianos tenemos
dificultades para vender pollos porque
la gente compra pollos chinos
los chinos los venden cuando sólo tienen
tres o cuatro semanas
los pollos chinos están llenos de
hormonas los pollos de zambia son buenos
a partir de las 5 semanas solo se les da
agua y semillas
sin productos químicos
los chinos los llenan de vitaminas
y es muy difícil competir con los chinos
son más baratos nuestros pollos son
gordos así que son caros venden los
suyos baratos queremos que los chinos se
vayan
un territorio casi una vez y media el
tamaño de francia cambia de rodesia del
norte se ha convertido en el 36º el
estado independiente de áfrica 100.000
sanz pianos felices han llegado hoy el
enorme estadio de lusaka para la
proclamación de la independencia y la
toma de posesión del nuevo presidente
cambia ancha en la relación entre zambia
y china comenzó antes de la
independencia
when the drawing los independentistas
necesitaron la ayuda de otros países
para luchar contra los colonos
británicos
y china fue uno de los países que los
apoyó que también china fue uno de los
primeros países en establecer relaciones
diplomáticas con zambia debido a estos
lazos históricos de background
cabe señalar que pocas horas antes de la
proclamación de la independencia se
llegó a un acuerdo sobre la disputa
entre el gobierno de rodesia del norte y
la compañía británica de sudáfrica por
los derechos mineros
la independencia le han seguido muchos
desafíos se cerró la frontera sur entre
zambia y rhodesia del sur actualmente
zimbabwe
la única manera de que zambia exportar a
su cobre era a través del puerto de dar
es salaam en tanzania
así el gobierno chino ayudó a construir
el ferrocarril que une zambia contactan
ya a partir de entonces los chinos se
convirtieron en los principales
contribuyentes al desarrollo de la
economía cambian
[Música]
no
cambiar el chip
[Música]
sí sí
lo único es que no hablamos de política
ni nada de preguntas sobre las
elecciones de san blas nada de políticas
tengo las últimas cifras acabo de
recibir un mensaje del asesor del
embajador en 2020 en inversión china en
xàbia alcanzó los 440 millones de
dólares
[Música]
es la inversión china más grande en
áfrica en el marco de la política china
de la nueva ruta de la seda cada vez más
empresas chinas se animan a invertir en
todo el continente africano
dotados
[Música]
alguna otra pregunta seas
se trata de la condición de chamizo para
someter la mente
la mayor fundición de cobre del
continente africano
también es la mayor fundición de cobre
de china en el extranjero
la pureza de este pobre superior al 98%
el asceta ccct ha atraído 2.700 millones
de dólares en inversión y hemos creado
10.000 puestos de trabajo
actualmente hay 74 empresas en la zona
todas las cadenas de producción se
realizan chile
[Música]
en occidente algunos piensan que china
está empezando a ocupar demasiado
espacio en áfrica cuál es su posición
esta es una gran pregunta
esa es realmente una pregunta difícil
básicamente nos estamos apropiando en
los recursos naturales es muy delicado
lo que puedo decirte es que en lo que
respecta a nuestro negocio
estamos aquí para integrarnos para crear
puestos de trabajo para los locales y
pagar impuestos
y a través de esta cooperación creamos
valor es un beneficio para todos los
gobiernos ha seguido nuestra empresa no
sólo exporta cobre a chile desde
entonces hecho de santander
sino que también vende a empresas
occidentales incluidas las francesas y
cuando con su poco acotó
bien vamos
oriente contra occidente era una
pregunta política
[Música]
nunca se es demasiado cuidadoso
tiene cifras sobre las exportaciones de
cobre a china luego tenemos cifras sobre
la industria minera lo cual es una
locura
y nadie las tiene
por qué
las empresas mineras son muy reservadas
hay pactos de transparencia sobre la
industria minera pero son pura mentiras
sabes cómo lo hacen
presentan una muestra del gobierno y
dicen aquí está el mineral es muy puro
pero la pureza real del cobre exportado
no se controla el éxito
[Música]
no no se encienden y cuando intentas
explicárselo hay un problema de
comunicación
no se preocupan por nosotros
ni siquiera se preocupan por nuestra
seguridad donde trabajo hay demasiado
polvo y si nos quejamos no nos escuchan
también son muy duros con el tema del
dinero
[Aplausos]
aquí ensambla la jornada laboral legal
es de 8 horas
trabajamos 12 horas al día
5 y te mostraré cuánto ganamos
ganamos ese monto por ocho horas de
trabajo y ahora por 12 horas nos pagan
lo mismo
creo que también quieren filmar aquí
esta es la zona residencial donde viven
los empleados chinos extendieron y
haddadi tenemos una cancha de tenis y
uno de baloncesto y no era tan alto y
aquí están las casas de los empleados ya
ni sin país somos como una gran familia
caguas la carling
[Música]
y aquí es donde viven nuestros empleados
de sanya
hola
este alguien ha limpiado su habitación y
les gustaría filmar una habitación
y normalmente la mayoría de nuestros
empleados cambian o se van a casa cada
noche pero con el móvil 19 hemos
renovado esta zona para convertirla en
una zona de cuarentena
shows de botanique
hay un comedor ese estado que entiendo
está mejor que en casa no hay lugar como
el lugar
todos vivimos en las mismas condiciones
para los chinos también es duro nosotros
también queremos ver a nuestras familias
pero juntos venceremos esta enfermedad
[Música]
ah
este terreno le pertenece a las setas sz
plantamos fresas estamos bajo cuarentena
así que estamos durmiendo aquí en la
compañía
solo en cuánto tiempo hace que no vea a
su familia familia
y desde abril del año pasado
cuando cree que volverá a verla
[Música]
si lo saben bien que no ya lo estaban
llenas los abanicos
pues a mi habana como
cabas anatoli de fans
fue la noche más sutil la manzana menos
fácil para situar a tu facebook visite a
mamá
como en villa miseria ya marcha de
inicio
la materia y amarilis
mi papá tú lees sescam es mi turno
copaba cenar tules timonel y tengo un
poco la base está
by aún mayor
[Música]
son más escasas aún más con soul trata
de nuestra pérdida de soberanía y
nuestra economía economics wyplosz con
soul band soy yo
en nuestro sistema social y político y
lo que quiero decir con esto es que las
empresas chinas en este país financian a
los políticos del partido en el poder
y financian sus proyectos personales
[Música]
sus campañas electorales
eso es un hecho en nuestro país windows
todo el mundo lo sabe
me resulta fácil señalar con el dedo a
los inversores chinos que maltratan a
sus empleados
porque lo hacen sin preocuparse de si
alguien los ha visto otros inversores
prefieren ocultar ciertas cosas
como las violaciones del código laboral
o las transacciones ilícitas
pero no solamente los chinos
lo hacen con tal impunidad que parecen
intocables
con el show del mundo puede ver lo que
están haciendo
podemos ver eso
escuchamos esas historias
todos los días we sing these things you
you hear the history ersinger
como periodista que creció en la verdad
es muy importante para mí seguiré sector
minero la producción los problemas
sindicales el desplazamiento de la
población el impacto medioambiental
es fundamental cubrir estas historias
la mayor parte de mis reportajes se
refieren a cuestiones mineras en la
línea 2 stories
al amor
h voluntad archi voluntad es un
activista por la tierra de los derechos
humanos es una muy buena fuente
hoy vamos a informar sobre la mina ene
efe s/a
que ha desplazado la población local
había familias viviendo allí la derecha
sus títulos de propiedad no eran claros
se consideró que ocupaban ilegalmente
las tierras pueden considerarse
atenciones
los trasladaron a diez o quince
kilómetros de distancia
hoy se encuentran en un lugar perdido
la carretera está en un estado de
lamentable
no hay transporte público por lo que les
resulta difícil ir a vender sus
productos para ellos es un reto diario
tienen que caminar hasta la carretera
principal aquí están las famosas casas
chinas
bueno
bueno bueno
[Música]
somos viejos son los pobres y ahora
tenemos que buscar tierras de cultivo en
otra parte y alquilar un campo cuesta
más de 100 dólares al mes
que es lo que más les hace falta aquí
pues el agua no tenemos agua
la carretera está toda averiada y no hay
clínica ni medicinas nada era mejor
donde vivía antes por supuesto
cultivamos nuestra propia tierra
teníamos cosas nunca nos quedamos sin
agua aquí nunca vemos a los funcionarios
locales electos no se aventuran hasta
este lugar se han olvidado de nosotros
no han cumplido sus promesas mira cómo
van vestidos nuestros hijos
sí
está al baño pero no hay agua
cuántos niños viven aquí 7
así que en esta casa y dos dormitorios
una cocina un salón y un baño para dos
adultos y siete niños en seven children
miranda no hay ventilación y por eso no
transpira groupon el aire no circula
dicen que la calidad de las casas está
bien pero que no son aireadas y son
demasiado pequeñas para esta familia
esta es la carta que nos dieron nos
prometieron que tendríamos títulos de
propiedad y dónde están sus títulos nos
han estafado
nos dejaron aquí como huérfanos como si
no fuéramos seres humanos eso es una
miseria
porque aceptaron venir aquí con afonía
para bajar nos obligaron a ir nos van a
mandar llegaron con una excavadora y
cargaron todas nuestras cosas en un
camión ya dijeron que si no nos íbamos
destruirían nuestras casas con todo lo
que quedaba adentro era la mitad de la
temporada de lluvias las excavadoras
destruyeron nuestras casas incluso antes
de que la gente se fuera estábamos
asustados nunca aceptamos venir aquí no
somos felices aquí
soy muy bajita
sí
[Música]
en la cultura china el agua y los peces
son símbolos de prosperidad y vida en
china era estresante
todos los días hacia horas extra el
ritmo de vida es más lento
la gente tiene prisa
no más despertares al amanecer por la
noche no tengo que tras luchar después
de las largas noches de trabajo
prefiero mi vida aquí
[Música]
echo de menos a mi familia por culpa del
joven los años que no los veo
[Música]
es lo que sí es el solía llorar mucho
ahora está mejor
[Música]
y comparándolo con beijing el tráfico
aquí no es un problema
llevo más de 10 años viendo me encanta
este país y áfrica en general
mi esposa está aquí los cambia no
siempre están de buen humor son muy
amables con los inversores extranjeros
como nosotros los chinos
tienen buen corazón filtramos gioja
afectan sale
[Música]
los altos cargos como yo conocen bien la
cultura cambias cambia y la actitud que
hay que adoptar con los ancianos
con jamón poco a poco la diferencia
cultural desarrollamos hayek y el
chilena de alta resolución
[Música]
cuando mis padres llegaron a asamblea
vinieron directamente a la granja en las
primeras noches estuvieron muy asustados
la tienda aquí por la noche los búhos a
los huevos y las águilas
hacen un ruido increíble
en china no tenemos este tipo de
ecosistema
[Música]
un vaso de alcohol no está bien no
tenemos nada sin alcohol
[Música]
la gente que nunca ha salido del país
piensa que en áfrica hace mucho calor y
que el color de la piel no viene el
bronceado los clichés sobre la guerra
civil las enfermedades
de hecho el clima es muy bueno en la
mayoría de los países africanos
los niños se enferman un poco aquí
porque el clima es muy bueno
conozco a muchas madres cuyos hijos
están sanos pero en cuanto llegan a
china se la pasan en el hospital de
memoria si tuviera que volver sería
difícil
nos hemos acostumbrado al ritmo de vida
de ejemplo
llevo 12 años en áfrica y no quiero
volver a china
[Música]
o no
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web las 24
punto com para ver está en las misiones
anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]